[Music]
guys and rainbows succeed shotguns can
do a lot more than just put holes in
walls so while they're often picked for
their environmental destructive
capabilities that can be pretty lethal -
that should have and a lot
oh yeah that's a bummer now with the
release of kayid we've seen a lot more
shotgun highlights lately but for this
video we're gonna focus on those more
classic style close-range shot ease now
while those guns have been around in the
game for a very long time a lot has
changed since years 1 & 2 which is why
we're not focusing on them for this
video now let's get on with it with the
top 10 shotgun kills in Rainbow six
siege kicking off our list at number 10
is ninjas at pajamas giulio who
perfectly demonstrates the level of
damage a fully automatic shotgun
conditioned in a match against immortals
The Alibi player caught the attackers
off guard and mowed down three enemies
in the clubhouse tunnel with the ACS 12
to meet you for the Immortals often
considered a meme loadouts ledges
shotgun is not the weapon of choice for
most situations dude who plays like
shotgun man but coming in at number 9 is
phase clans Gohan who shows us that the
shotgun can be a viable pick in this one
v3 clutch against ninjas in pyjamas wait
what maybe next year the shotgun on our
sledge Donegan will actually make it
work he needs to defend it against the
lettuce bonus he sprays all his swag
to him but camicazi he does not have
enough time on the bouquet on the
shotgun we made fun of the sled shoddy
but you know what he whips it up with
like John Gotti gets the last two yep
the round no time for the lesion there's
nothing more satisfying than having a
shotgun while enemies sprint at you
single file and our number eight plays
these teamliquid
doing just that making it easy for team
vitality x' breed aid to clutch out this
one before with the shotgun
there's no diffuser it's not been said
just yet they put it on the other side
will you deal with one canister right
into second cake gonna right in the face
oh my god what is that what a defensive
window
oh just clutching it up so hard coming
in at number 7 is boot camp gaming's
lightzord who in a 1v3 after plant
situation shows us just how deadly smoke
can be in the close quarters of Oregon's
basement he's got a shotgun out but
we'll need to stop them what it's shot
on the psycho oh my you'll see what a
double from life he's got one left
kamikaze like with the pig clutch blasts
through the chest
game over a huge clutch from light and
he'll get the defuse give a bootcamp
around that they had no business winning
if they win it anyway
smoke is arguably sieges most iconic
shotgun operator and our number six play
is the perfect example of why that is
tasked with a 2v5 during a season 7 pro
league relegation match supremacy tactus
makes use of both his weapons to take
out all five of enza's members it'll go
for another on the tactics but he can't
connect
that's a double answered back from the
smokes of supremacy and it's tactics and
alive alive who was creeping just
outside a saint will need to come back
in but now tactics takes out a third
this is gonna be another clutch for
supremacy they'll need to grab the
defuser uno has it tactics coming in
he'll get a shotgun tactics this is one
left off pleeeease for tactics as
supremacy goes up three to nothing
what a finish known for his incredible
clutches three days 1v3 against ends
during Dreamhack Valencia semi-finals
comes in at number five on our list with
a beautiful long range kill on a shotgun
the smoke not only closed out the round
but also secured the ACE and then that
would of course help both teams where we
can see quick rotation but the great
shot from red using that very narrow
angle the plants going to go down from
Boone see what see here underneath the
coverage of smoke but their green smoke
is gonna get them and this is where
somebody else is gonna have to take
possession we do see Blasket time before
coffee see if some just before he gets
taken aight well he almost like one who
you mind will kill him has bred well
rooted behind blasts gets picked up and
shot anyway in the died it's been a
commute Wilkie doctor what if it has to
be Brad day in that car watch water
clutch from the Smulian and my colleague
Nick the lead going into this rule swamp
that should not have happened there that
was just the shotgun doing shotgun
things and number four is cloud nines
goddess on echo with a primary weapon as
great as the mp5 SD it's rare to see
echo shotgun but during Dreamhack
Montreal 2018 semi finals goddess found
three kills on the supernova with just
enough time left to clutch out the round
goddess gets one retro is down so it's a
glorified to v3 but next to no timing
goddess the second live and we'll finish
off retro it's just boxing goddess
wrenched arrow holds that diffuser is
there a yokai in play to possibly stop
this in its tracks there we go tagging
me Blackbeard he's very low on HP
they'll push but goddess is there on
time can cloud9 get it on defuse his
range zero
that'll be North America going into the
finals cloud9 Belling millennium 77-69
the first team to go to your dreamhack
Montreal finals it just couldn't make
this list without including the iconic
Guevara play from last year's six major
Grand Final which is why it finds its
way at number three on our list while
the highlight of the play is the
interrogation let's not forget that unis
ran over to members of Evil Geniuses
with the spaz 15 to make it all happen
be planting in the backs of meantime you
want us goes in for the parade the NPK
will go down let's go guys being lost by
young holding the ankle extra gas
canister shot in the back of the owner
again the second kill one more up top
our runner-up spot goes to phase clans
Moringa considered one of the best
smoked players in the world
Moringa went on an absolute tear in a
match against Norah Rango at the season
8 Pro League seven finals I mean
seriously you just have to see it sends
down one toxic day but I'll drop the
bucket
great play outside the boulder top
events it even is there as well what
kind of magic can unit take slow going
here Fedora but luckily for them they've
been efficient and their take so far and
have time Moringa will take down Mary oh
but it doesn't seem that he knows he's
down his opponent which means Mary you
can be salvaged again takes the time put
the run out for Moringa and he will
secure marry you
there's no one there to get a reef rag
and Moringa will eat some damage on the
retreat but the fire bolt might actually
finish him off
no it's just inches away the bump from
JJ though we'll take down Yuna Maringa
on low HP means it's just cameraman it
seems in the 1 versus 2 whirring earth
he still has the shotgun in hand though
and he's been landing his shot I was
around then you know where the guy who's
killing is they had the information on
Noriko they knew his position there was
minimal coverage their best taking the
crown for Rainbow six siege is best
shotgun kill is the time fanatics basis
gave zero [ __ ] as he jumped out of
armory to gun down three attackers with
the fo 12 essentially securing the match
against evil geniuses there's not much
more we can say the shots almost
connected from aces he is back on that
foot 12 again there we go fnatic or
closer in closer he's still on the
outside the fo 12 we've seen living
through this on millennium what do you
miss you went to North America right now
absolutely shredding them neo and what
take it away he says we'll drop it but
not enough to finish off the ash the
waves careful boys last man alive is
neck cross this MV Ches on the floor
with a 2-0 well guys that's all we got
for you this week now if you did like
this content and you do want to see more
our six stuff well you know what to do
pump that like button and unload the
buckshot into the comment section and
I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button